[Music]
today we revisiting the GTX 1080 and the
greatest video card that Nvidia ever
made the GTX 1080
ti What was what was that not only did
the 1080 TI come out at a time when it
was just the TI and not the ti or the
tii taii or the super taii or the taii
super all of those came later it was
they innovate in different ways every
time it was also the greatest card that
Nvidia has ever made and we've regularly
said it's a mistake that they probably
won't make again this card is the goat
absolutely no questions about it and
it's actually why I still have a 1080ti
in my personal system at home it's
actually an SC2 icx model uh that I
liked when we reviewed it and now it's
retired from service and in my machine
so it's good enough that depending on
the games you play especially if you
don't play RT or something they can
still handle it and they're 7 years old
the 1080 TI is such a good car that we
have now Revisited it at least two or
three times maybe more I've lost count
and Google has gotten worse as a search
engine but we've Revisited it a lot and
it's worth doing again because now
there's the whole Super Series the 700 J
basically everything has launched for
this generation in theory anyway uh and
so we can take a complete look at where
it stands today and what your options
are uh and also for this revisit we have
a couple new types of charts just to try
and capture the most relevant things as
fast as possible for those of you who
might still be on one of these cards and
if you're not on one and you just want
to look back at something that was
impressive for its time maybe this will
give a new perspective as to why before
that this video is brought to you by
montech and the k95 pro case the k95 pro
is a dual chamber enclosure with
configurable options for storage and
power supplies the k95 has a deep 35mm
cable channel for management support for
dual power supplies if you want it which
could be useful for a thread rer system
and ample radiator and fan mounting
options scattered around the the top
back bottom side and front of the case
the front also can be mesh or solid with
the mesh running a higher paracity for
more breathability learn more at the
link in the description below one of the
things that made the 1080 ti so good was
that it was typically about $100 more
than a GTX 1080 maybe 200 depending on
which price you're looking at that was
an ERA where Nvidia was experimenting
with having two launch prices because uh
we needed that in our lives they've
improved in that respect at least but
typically it was a $1 to $200 price jump
between the 1080 and the 1080 TI and
given the performance gap which we'll
look at in a moment between these two
for the first time against each other in
years actually we haven't tested them
both on the same charts in a while it
really made sense to go for the 1080ti
for people who could afford it the RTX
20 series launch though is really what
cemented the 1080ti in its place as the
greatest of all time the launch of the
RTX 2080 saw us telling everyone to just
buy a 1080ti instead that's because they
could still be had for believe it or not
around $700 at that time which made it
often 100 bucks cheaper than the average
2080 maybe 50 if $50 cheaper if you
bought one of the cheaper 2080s uh and
it was extremely competitive the MSI
Armor Series was a Bare Bones kind of
garbage tier cooler for the 1080ti as
far as that generation of coolers went
anyway but it was a an MSRP option at
700 box that we liked because you got a
good enough vrm you could strip the
cooler from it didn't feel like you were
throwing away a ton of cost in it uh and
then throw a hybrid cooler on it like a
CLC with a vrm fan that was really
popular for the era you suddenly had a
very budget conscious water cooled cold
enough to overclock 1080 TI and that's
another aspect of what made these cards
so damn good the power for V bios gave
you more Headroom to overclock than
you'll find on a lot of modern cards
today but the real reason the 20 series
set the 1080 TI up for such success was
because it launched with no namesake
feature it was called RTX there was no
RTX it was about 2 months before the
first RTX game launched uh I remember
talking about it in news segments where
we were like 55 days without RT title uh
and at the time that was when RT real
time RT was still kind of a a new thing
being marketed it hadn't proven itself
and there's no reason to review or buy a
product based on a promise and so when
the 1080 TI was matching or sometimes
exceeding a 2080 uh and it was often
cheaper it didn't make a lot of sense to
buy a 2080 and it would be years before
RT became really truly meaningfully
relevant in any atlarge way so the 1080
TI immediately if didn't already have it
gained legendary status with the launch
of the 20 series the pricing was a big
part of that where the 20 series saw the
2080 TI coming in at 1,200 bucks or
whatever it was plus or minus a little
bit uh and that just felt like such a
climb compared to this card that
whatever status it had not yet earned
the 1080 TI It earned with the 20 series
launch so uh this still even seven years
later and close to eight years later for
the 1080 non TI which is also worth
talking about can still handle a lot of
games it can still play at a reasonable
FPS in non-r traced scenarios you lack
some Modern features you don't have rt
Hardware there's kind of limited
natively supported upscaling options so
it has limitations and it's starting to
show age but depending on what you play
you might not even need to upgrade it
and if you're ready to upgrade at least
it is a massive jump from 7even years
ago that's some pretty damn good mileage
out of a video car some additional
history here the 1080 TI launched in
March of 2017 about a year after the
1080s launch in 2016 it was a powerful
onew punch for NVIDIA at the time its
newest competition from AMD for the
1080ti would have been the RX 580 which
launched in April of 2017 and that
itself was just a refresh of the 480
otherwise the 1080ti was up against an
aging generation of Fury cards Vega
wouldn't come out for another several
months after the 1080 TI's launch and
largely to disappointing reception and
this is part of what we're trying to do
today we've Revisited this card so many
times from a performance aspect today
it's about providing some extra
provenance and background especially for
people who hear about the 108ti you see
people say it was legendary it was the
goat not sure why we're trying to give
some of that context and I still
remember covering all of this as it was
happening because it was an exciting
time uh this was an ERA where AMD was
absolutely plagued and riddled with
driver problems we had multiple videos
on them back then I remember posting one
that was titled something along the
lines of like AMD sabotages itself again
or something like that and we talked
about drivers all the time for them so
Nvidia was in an overpowering position
uh and and these drivers at the time
were so riddled with bugs that if the
drivers had a door opening that door was
like opening the door to a roach
infested room where you just see them
all scatter Andy's drivers though have
gained substantially since then that era
is largely gone for Amy they fixed those
problems it's nothing like it used to be
so huge Improvement for from AMD side of
things and its modern generation of
cards is much more competitive than what
it was fighting with back then which
before Vega launched wasn't a lot at
least not a lot of brand new
architecture stuff uh and so at that
time AMD mostly chose to fight in the
mid-range Market they had $250 rx580s
which looking back was actually a pretty
damn good card and even at the time I
think pretty much everyone recognized it
as the best mid-range option in a lot of
cases and that market is kind of dead
today which is sad we maybe took it for
granted at the time where we had the
1080 TI at the top end as an inarguable
best and we had things like the rx580
keeping that affordable class alive in a
way that today you don't really get that
type of competition until you go up to
400 bucks or so maybe 500 uh where you
really start to see the market get
interesting so it was a a much different
time for the market and gpus and the
prices were a lot different let's let's
go over that quickly though so we have
some price data with inflation
adjustment the GTX 1080ti was often $700
like with the armor card and it ran up
to 800 pretty frequently there were more
expensive cards as always but these two
price points cover the vast majority of
relevant options today a $700 purchase
of the 1080ti would be equivalent to
spending $88.75 according to US
inflation data an $800 purchase would be
equivalent to
$1,006 if you look at gpus available
right now that $880 adjusted price would
be an RTX 47 TI super from Nvidia or an
rx700 XTX from AMD flanking each end the
$1,000 inflation adjusted 1080ti price
if you bought it that higher end back
then would be an RTX 480 sup MSRP if you
can find one at MSRP or again a 7900 XTX
back to the inflation table the GTX 1080
was $600 to $700 commonly and again
remember that Nvidia made this all very
messy with its e price and at the time
we're kind of ignoring that aspect
that'd be a 766 to 894 pricing inflation
adjusted today equivalent would again
include the 4070 TI super from Nvidia or
the 7900 XT up to maybe the 7900 XTX
from AMD what's Wild is the used price
of the 1080 TI in a quick look around
they seem to have sold listings on eBay
for 150 to 200 bucks or so and sometimes
cheaper if you buy one with a broken fan
which is an easy fix that makes a used
1080ti a better option than nvidia's
modern $ 150 to $200 video cards or
sometimes even it's $300 card if you're
willing to sacrifice RT so in a way
Nvidia own Masterpiece remains kind of a
thorn in its side to the extent that at
a launch event Jensen went on stage and
he said something about to all my Pascal
gamer friends it is safe to upgrade now
and that was because of cards like this
and the 1070 The 1060 was fairly
competitive too now the 3080 did really
well to reset the whole pricing stack
following the 2080 it felt like a breath
of fresh air it was lined up to be
another 1080 TI in terms of its
reception but the rug got pulled out
from under it because of the immediate
boom where it was no longer available
and when it was available they were
scaled and way overpriced so that kind
of killed the momentum on the 3080 but
it was kind of lining up still though
nothing has quite touched the 1080ti so
let's get into some numbers we'll start
with reestablishing our bearings for how
the 1080 and the 1080t I compared to
each other today this factors in the
latest drivers for each the Windows
updates that are the latest and
modernized changes to the BIOS firmware
things like that the OS as well such as
rebar Hardware accelerated GPU
scheduling here's the chart this shows
percent improvement from a 1080 to a
1080 TI in the various games we test in
2024 it's remarkably consistent from
game to game in this era even across
resolutions that's a big difference from
what we see with cards today where
Nvidia in particular plays with memory
bandwidth in ways that create less
predictable or at least less linear
scaling across the resolutions the GTX
1080 TI is generally about 35% faster
than the 1080 and average FPS for
today's benchmarks if you had waited
until the 1080ti launched and spent
about $100 more max maybe around $200
more than the 1080 then that money
stretched out pretty well and could have
been a deciding factor in stretching the
card out for maybe one more generation
as a side note it's rare that we see
something like 38% uplift within a
single vendor stack for a hundred bucks
today it doesn't really happen anymore
and the few times it does happen they're
pretty rare uh broadly speaking looking
at the consistency of improvement of
those numbers for the price at the time
again something like a 100 bucks maybe
150 sometimes it just it seems like it
will never happen again and like it was
almost a mistake okay on to the next
table since we've recapped the 1080 ti
so much again we're experimenting with
some different charts this is a
different one
uh we're using a simple table that
Recaps several games we've tested in one
shot but what it does is uh in the First
Column it's going to show you the most
immediate trailing card so the one
that's the most comparable to the 1080
TI but right behind it the other column
shows you the most immediate advantaged
card ahead of it the middle is something
roughly equal now all three of those
together because it's immediate
immediate and then roughly equal you end
up with basically what is the equivalent
today that's what this table will answer
and serves to help you get a a sort of
quick snapshot of your minimum threshold
you want to clear to actually get a
meaningful upgrade ideally you go a
little bit beyond that too this also
helps you figure out a baseline so this
part's important where going forward if
we or other reviewers drop the 108ti
from charts but you want to know where
it falls you look at this list of
equivalents and then in the future if
you know it's roughly equivalent to card
X and the 108ti is not on someone's
chart you look for card X and you go
okay it's probably probably around here
it's not perfect but it's good enough to
kind of keep it in keep it fresh with
knowing where it lands here it is the
most immediately behind modern
architecture GPU is generally the 6600
6600 XT or nvidia's 60 class cards like
the RTX 3060 and 4060 Intel Arc also
makes a few appearances and this tells
you that if you wanted to upgrade you
would need to buy at least better than
these cards in a modern lineup to get
any meaningful Improvement at all and
ideally you'd go a couple steps up from
them to ensure it actually is Meaningful
and not just basically a side grade with
Ray tracing capabilities the closest of
any generation we've recently tested is
variable here we see that the 2070 super
makes an appearance a few times and the
7600 But it really depends on the game
tested the 2080 also makes an appearance
in that column for the most immediately
advantaged modern generation card the
1080ti is commonly beaten most
immediately by the same cards as were
immediately behind it this makes sense
because when a card is plus or minus a
few percentage points it'll swing either
direction depending on the game the 4060
appears the most here if you're not
buying at least a 4070 or a 6700 XT as a
replacement generally speaking we don't
think it'd be worth buying a new card if
you can do it it's maybe more sensible
to save up a little longer if possible
and buy something another click or two
up let's look at this another way
instead of looking at the immediate
flank since that largely comes out to be
the same set of cards sort of across the
stack we're going to look at the most
likely upgrades for a quick snapshot and
for this we're looking at similar
pricing inflation adjusted so in other
words someone who wants to spend a
similar amount of money in value back
then today what might you get for uplift
that's what we're looking at and we have
some others that are a little bit lower
in price we're going to go through as
well that are maybe more similar to like
to like back then uh and we'll talk
about more that with the 1080 also this
also helps you understand what the
difference between $150 or $300 extra
might get you
uh if you're upgrad you're buying a new
card today what's that Gap look like if
you spend a little more here it is
against a bunch of games the 10ed ti
itself is not shown that's because it's
the left Axis or the Baseline we're
looking at percent improvement over
Baseline and average FPS this is one of
those scenarios where anything would be
an upgrade generally speaking you can
expect somewhere around a 120 to 150%
uplift or so with a 4070 TI super just
looking across this Suite of games the
4080 super roughly speaking would be
around 170 to 190% uplift the XT is
around 140 to 160% for uplift with the
XTX at 190 to 210% or so just broadly
speaking each of these has several
breakouts including the 7900 XTX in
particular spiking upwards of 300%
Improvement in Starfield at that point
percentages don't really feel like they
mean anything anymore so suffice to say
it's an entirely different experience
you should basically be choosing between
the modern cards that you're considering
rather than necessarily comparing them
to the 1080ti because all of these are
going to be massive changes in the
experience but it's still fun to look
back and get a feel for it this way the
next recap is for the GTX 1080 non TI
for this one we're comparing against the
470 super the 470 TI super the RX 7900
GRE that just got a global launch and
the RX 7900 XT the 470 super is the same
price that the 1080 launched when
ignoring inflation or it would be the
equivalent of $470 at launch like back
then the 700 GRE as a similar price
today or including inflation would be
about $431 back at launch and that gives
us two cards priced similarly with
inflation and two priced below here's
the chart the 1080ti doesn't appear here
since we've already shown a summary
chart for that but as a reminder that
generally be around 35% uplift from the
1080 for the rest you can get increases
in average FPS in the multiples even
with something at an equal price today
when ignoring inflation in other words
even if your buying power hasn't kept up
with inflation you can at least get a 2
to 3x increase in many scenarios with
the 470 super the 470 TI super is better
enough that it may help pull you forward
another year than the 470 super though
that depends so much on how much you're
willing to lower the graphic settings
what games come out that it's hard to
really make estimates like that but uh
you're paying for that theoretical
longevity the 7900 GRE also provides
significant uplift while being cheaper
than $600 and is one of the more
relevant cards at this price point right
now the 700xt is just in a completely
different class of rasterization
performance altogether uh it blows these
away the biggest difference though would
be in R tracing where you're going from
basically not compatible to compatible
on any of these modern devices now we're
about to get into the individual game
test just to give some foundational data
with more charts but uh rate tracing
kind of remains the key Point here that
doesn't get charts because the 1080 TI
does not natively or meaningfully
support rat racing uh realtime rat
racing with modern games so because of
that there's not really anything to test
it's your number is basically zero and
or unplayable enough to be zero if you
were to force it in some scenarios where
you can and so for ra tracing results
just look at our 7900 GRE review any
other recent review look at the RT chart
that gives you an idea but you're not
really choosing between how much better
is it than a 10ed ATI uh because it
might as well be infinitely better okay
we'll quickly run through some game
charts but because we've already covered
the major comparisons here there not a
lot more to talk about we'll make this
quick you can pause these if you want to
check out cards that we haven't
explicitly mentioned otherwise we'll
focus on the key highlights and Final
Fantasy 14 at 4K the 1080ti still
manages to hold the 62 FPS average so no
problems here that has it at 3060 TI
levels of performance and actually
surpassing the 2080 somewhat
embarrassingly for the touring card the
1080 FTW ran at about 76 600 levels of
performance flanked by the two available
models and this chart actually also
contains an overclock we ran for the
1080ti last year when we did a different
revisit and that data is still valid for
this game because the results for this
title don't change with our test
approach so that OC had it up at about
6700 XT average FPS surpassing the 4060
TI in DL 2 at 1080p the GTX 1080 sat
below the 6600 in our most recent round
of testing the 3060 also leads it
somewhat significantly the 108 TI has
done excellently to hang on here but in
some heavier modern games it's beginning
to fall to the bottom of the chart of
note even Intel's a750 is outdoing the
1080 TI in this one the RTX 380 is
another good reference point up about
151 FPS average to the 1080ti 74 or the
1080s 55 one last note you can see the
1% lows dipped down on the 1080
indicative of where some of the
generational improvements have been
invested over the years 1440p stretches
the scale to the point that the 1080 TI
now Falls below 60 FPS so if we choose
60 FPS as a somewhat arbitrary line of
scrimmage the first card that passes it
is the a770 on this chart with the 7600
XT and the 2080 close enough for
non-intel you might consider the 470 or
the 7800 XT as meaningfully improved
with the 1080ti but probably with less
staying power than you benefited from
the 1080ti and realistically the 4070 if
you're coming from at least just a
naming perspective feels like a a more
of a step aside or a step down even than
the original 10d DTI purchase but it's
still objectively better in Starfield at
1440p tested mostly because it helps us
avoid non GPU limitations higher up the
stack at say 1080p the GTX 1080s
performance had it about tied with an
Intel a750 GPU Intel struggles with
Starfield so it's not the best
comparison and so we can instead turn to
the 6600 and the RTX 3060 which both
post large gains over the GT TX 1080
despite neither being a recommended path
forward from this card this and the
1080ti alike would be hugely improved
upon by nearly anything in the chart
1440p is heavy with this game on these
cards they were capable 1440p players at
the time and even some 4K but games have
also gotten heavier in the years since
Pascal at 4K the Pascal cards really
just can't handle the game they're
clearly struggling their results are
less consistent as a result of this load
fortunately not much was lost because
it's Starfield but to get any meaningful
uplift might mean a jump to a 7800 XT uh
a used RTX 380 as a great option or the
4070 super in Rainbow Six Siege at 1080p
were served a reminder that both of
these cards can still be objectively
capable performers for the right title
this combination of resolution and game
still puts the goat 1080 TI into the
hundreds of FPS average approaching 300
actually with even its slower 1080
counterpart still surpassing 200 FPS
average if you're not playing the heavy
VI games at higher resolutions and if
you don't always need the max settings
then in an objective sense these are
still good enough and this is a great
reminder of that anyone ultra
competitive in a game like this might
notice a latency difference between the
1080 TI and the 470 super here but
generally speaking if you're not
noticing the performance of your 10
series card as being bad then there's no
shame in sticking with it to us it's a
sense of Pride that's actually why I
still have my 1080 TI in my home machine
at 1440p the GTX 1080 still holds 30 FPS
average in Rainbow Six Siege with the
1080 TI continuing to impress and earn
its goat title all 7 years later now
we're still seeing performance
equivalent to a 2070 super in this one
and besting the modern a750 noteworthy
entries on this one Remain the RTX 380
which would still give a huge upgrade
pathway while potentially running cheap
if you're willing to trust a used
listing the new RX 7900 GRE also johs
ahead for something at a balanced price
at 4K the Pascal cards both manage to
keep their frame rate above 60 FPS the
1080ti ftw3 held an impressive 83 here
tying it with the 2070 super and the
7600 XT and the 1080 FTW ran at 62 about
the same as the 6600 XT they're still
hanging in there another option we
haven't discussed is a potential used
3070 but it really have to be cheap
enough to be worthwhile other cards
probably feel a lot better to move to
than a 3070 if you're a current 1080 or
1080 TI owner uh If Only from the sort
of Psychological Association with the
naming it feels like a downgrade if you
can get a 6950 XT for 500 bucks or so
that's another one that people are
probably sleeping on these days Resident
Evil 4 at 1080p is up now another one of
the relatively new titles in the suite
this one has the 1080 TI at 101 FPS
average and the 1080 at 74 it's not bad
the 1080 TI puts up a performance not
distant from the 2080 just ahead of the
207 super and the 1080 Trails the 3060
here this is still playable on both
though at 1440p the 1080 FTW slips to
about 50 FPS average still playable but
less enjoyably the 1080ti maintains an
overall good frame rate and is
effectively tied with the RTX 4060 you'd
want to buy into a higher class of card
if upgrading otherwise it' just be the
same in rasterization except with rt
support for Less intensive RT titles on
the AMD side the 6950 XT remains worth
paying attention to in the used Market
as does the 3080 for used for new cards
the 7900 XT remains hard to beat for its
value with its 7 $100 pricing these days
or up to 720 or so and for NVIDIA the
4070 super might be one of the stronger
modern values at 4K both cards struggle
they fall off more as resolution
increases in these modern games the 1080
TI manages to hang on to 2080 equivalent
reminding us of exactly why our 2080
launch day review conclusion was to just
go buy a 1080 TI while you still could
because remember at that time there were
literally zero RTX games the first RTX
Game Wouldn't launch for another two
months and because we're not in the
business of reviewing promises the
1080ti just made way more sense back
then it was comparatively cheap too it's
incredible how many generations this
card has managed to survive and remain
playable and matching the 2080 really
proves that finally in GTA 5 the 1080
held a 56 FPS average and was between
the 5700 XT and the 360 this is at 4K
the 1080ti continues to impress and
outmatches the 4060 TI it's a hell of a
show from Pascal finally just for fun
here's some power consumption numbers in
a total 100% workload we have the 108ti
at about 280 Watts that has it more
power hungry than the 7900 GRE so if
nothing else cards have definitely
gotten way more power efficient over the
years in terms of FPS it's similar to
the 407t non super with an overclock we
had the 1080 TI at 325 watts and that's
another aspect that goated the card its
OC Headroom was often enormous with
board Partners more enabled to expand
the total power budget than you'll often
find in a V bios today this has it
around 7900 XT and 3080 levels so that's
kind of the wrapup to recap some of the
pricing the 4070 super it's like the
same price if you ignore inflation uh
it's cheaper if you factor it in
something like 470 bucks the 470 TI
super is the same price back then with
inflation and uh meaning if you spent
that amount of money today and then you
got in a time machine went back you'd be
buying a 1080 TI with roughly the same
money the 7900 GRE is cheaper IGN oring
inflation it's about $431 in 2016 uh and
then the 700xt is similar price with
inflation now the inflation numbers are
coming from US Government data for the
numbers specifically we compared uh the
launch date for the 1080ti the precise
date against December of 2023 they
didn't have 2024 data available yet and
uh as for the accuracy of it I I don't
know ask the US government it's a little
it's above my head so but uh those are
kind of the numbers to consider
ultimately if you you feel like your
buying power is about the uh the same as
it was then then you're looking at
something like maybe 4070 TI 700 XT
something in that range anyway the
1080ti holds on to its Crown as the goat
and at this point it's not going to let
go of it this card will go down as
completely legendary when it eventually
gets retired from our benches but until
a point at which it can't really run
things anymore we're going to keep it in
as many charts as we can because it's
just it's fun to continue seeing how
well it's holding
this is genuinely people occasionally in
the comments will ask what cards or what
Hardware I've enjoyed reviewing the most
what I've most genuinely liked working
on uh in my 15 or so years doing this
and earnestly the 1080 TI is probably in
my top three things I've ever worked on
it might be number one uh some of that
is because it was it was a bit of a
formative era for us as an outlet uh
where this specific generation of cars
from AMD and Nvidia was one where we
were really starting to learn a lot of
the processes and uh the performance
remains impressive for the price so
anyway if you're looking to buy
something new first of all uh depending
on what CPU you're running but if you're
on a platform from that era probably
should consider buying it to something
newer just so you don't uh sort of
hamstring the performance of a new card
too much but 4070 TI super 700 XT 700
XTX price has actually come down to like
900 to 950 bucks these days 6950 XT if
used 380 if used those are kind of the
starting points 4070 super if you're
looking to spend a little less but still
get a meaningful uplift and uh some
actual RT it does seem however that if
you're trying to find what's the next
TI doesn't really seem like there is one
right now the 380 was lined up for it
but couldn't quite take that title the
490 is definitely the closest Contender
but it's price just it takes away a lot
of the power that it would have in terms
of that associate
people would make with something like
the 108 it's got to be a combination of
the two together that make something as
special as this card was so anyway it
still plays games uh if you're not into
RT or don't care yet and if you can get
by on either older titles or
1080p then I think my personal message
for people would be if you don't feel
like your 1080 or your 1080 TI is
underperforming for you don't upgrade
just wait till the next Generation you
stretch it out a little longer put
bigger gaps between those card purchases
and you're stretching your money a
little further for other things in life
uh of course if you feel like it's time
to upgrade then there are plenty of
options we've given you the numbers but
this was really fun for us I love doing
this kind of look back at things and if
you're interested in more things like
this go watch our 3dfx Voodoo revisit we
did it with a modern handmade replica of
a voodoo card it's an awesome video
Patrick wrote the script for that thing
and uh that was an awesome piece we also
have an article on gamer nexus.com net
if you want to just read it click on
gpus thanks for watching go to store.
gam access.net to support us directly by
grabbing something like one of our mod
mats or one of our soldering and project
Maxs we'll see you next time